we both early on in our show business
careers took tap-dancing because we
thought that was going to come in handy
when I was a kid I wanted to be in show
business and I was this goofy kid living
in Boston with orange hair and I told my
folks I mean show business Sunday in
show business you have to tap dance my
voice changed like two years ago and but
I literally did think I had to tap dance
and and you and so I took tap-dancing
lessons this was like you know it's like
1979 at this point no one captain did
you tap dance to wait you so you're like
a really good you're pretty really good
tepid no no I took it for a couple years
but then I stopped because everyone beat
me with sticks yeah they they wrote it
in a script so I learned it shuffle off
to Buffalo shuffle off to Buffalo that's
the old step yeah yeah yeah that's good
you know that old show business stuff
isn't it oh yeah yeah but like why Wally
I'm doing so well yeah you know they're
they're doing oh I'm a jerk
Amish don't think they're paying homage
yeah yeah that's yeah old uh stylin yeah
yeah you know what you were a delightful
fellow you really are I like very you
know I like talking to you and you're
you've got a you're very genuine I like
that you I think it's something about
not living here in the business a lot of
kids they come out here they work in the
business two years later you know
they're just punks they need a beating
what's that beep it sticks like you were
with them I would never I would never be
the travel sticks how dare you accuse me
that
you